how does she come back that from
everything that goes down in that final
episode how does she come back from this
and Gilead I don't know actually I can't
tell you and the Lord said I have seen
my people in bondage and I have heard
their cry how is aunt Lydia gonna deal
with this situation
such a good question they've hung in
there together for a very long time and
what seems like an absurd odd if you
will friendship
I think they admire strengths in each
other and the vulnerability in each
other it's a very complicated
relationship which is writing love about
it
I think this year is about June becoming
really a fighter you know going up
against Gilead and actually
accomplishing something she also takes a
bullet in her efforts we have a sense of
joy and accomplishment for what she
accomplished with those children and we
also have to figure out how to get her
out of the well because at the moment
she's in the bottom of a well but we
will we will we always followed June
through June story in fact I was like we
let her lead us so you know the next
step after you become a rebel and
actually kill people and then shed blood
and have people shed blood for you then
whatever comes after that it's our next
step one thing you really yeah I think
it's time I was gonna say we didn't get
much Nick this season but some people
are wondering is she's sticking around
for Hannah for Nick for both twofer I'm
she's sticking around for Hannah yeah I
actually I actually think that it was
interesting moved to kind of not make it
about a love story and I think it's
actually interesting that we kind of put
that to the side at the same time you
know I love the Nick Jun relationship as
much as anyone if not more so I miss
Nick - I think you should come back this
is your chance to be a father
my daughter could we see more nick in
season four oh absolutely I don't think
I saw enough of him this year either max
is terrific
such a wonderful actor and we love
having him the show and it's just you
know what as I said you follow Jun in
the ebb and flow of that sometimes it
leads you away from all the stories you
want to tell but yes you know he's both
Nick and Max are a favorite of ours as
well and he's intimately involved in
where Serena's story is going so we got
that to play with that are bad forced
your driver to impregnate with
Osbourne's he could claim the result in
child Nichkhun offered had a
relationship
it's still rape this is water food what
do you want to see for Rita in season
four I really want to see that first
initial conversation with the water
first when we're on an even playing
field right now when they they're fine
that there's finally no hierarchy our
roles I want to see how that
conversation goes because we've learned
that Rita has such an empathetic heart
and I'm wondering if it will turn now
that she doesn't get to be as empathetic
anymore or I wonder if someone's going
to get punched what is the number one
question you want answered in season
four
who's my cellmate I hope it's not a big
burly chap that has predispositions like
Christopher Maloney's characters could
be an asset I think Fred and Serena
certainly have a lot of stuff to work
out in their marriage and there's enough
people up there that there's there are
strong stories coming in there and also
I think the show kind of has an
obligation to represent an accurate
refugee experience because so many of
our characters are either trapped or
they're going to be refugees so those
are always your choices so you really
have to represent that option as a true
option of what it's really like are we
going to be exploring Canada a lot more
well we have a lot of characters who are
in little America and they've found some
peace Gilead stays within you and you
have to carry that forward and just
because you are in Canada to start the
year I don't know doesn't mean you'll
stay there
yeah
it's really good to me
also I'm hoping that there's going to be
some sort of coup like in Canada that we
go and try to get her out because I know
that we're all connected now all of our
characters so I hope that we're gonna
have a gang and try to smuggle her out
on our end do you think there's ever a
world where Lydia flips to the other
side you know it wouldn't surprise me
I'm gonna tell you because she didn't
come from there didn't come from Gilead
you know she was a teacher she loves
children has she kept that space where
love could happen safe and can we
somehow get better it feels like we are
really moving ahead here so is there an
end game in sight kind of a final plan
in place or is it still taking June
story one season at a time I I
definitely have possible end games in
sight but you know when they're all
gonna coalesce into kind of a finish
episode and something you can put nicely
in the shelf next of your copy of
Handmaid's Tale take a nice deep breath
really darling nice deep breath it's all
gonna be fine and we'll get there
somehow and we'll be waiting for you
next season and thank you for being so
wonderful such wonderful plans
there's
[Music]
you